quick shout out to those who also drew
hitler mustaches on my posters by the
[Music]
[Applause]
way
huh
it's okay and thank you for coming as
well i hope you enjoyed your experience
by the way that's good news for a few
people in the standby line so the idea
that jim crow made places richer made
the american economy richer or that
slavery made the american economy richer
is obviously untrue if slavery had been
an economic winner
this dude don't worry there's q a if you
want to be the first person in the q a
if you want me the first person the q a
it can be you
okay
[Applause]
okay you perfectly
perfectly welcome perfectly welcome to
ask a question
if slavery had been an economic winner
the south wouldn't have been roundly
defeated by the industrialized north
the end of slavery meant a drop in
agricultural capital in the united
states and a massive uptick in
industrial and housing capital as well
as in other domestic capital
according to far less econ far-left
economist thomas pichetti
our labor stock sword our capital stock
sword in the aftermath of the civil war
dude like really you can ask a question
i promise i promise you the first person
asks a question
your free speech is during the q a dude
i mean like
well nobody hired you to come up here
and talk so if you want to convince
somebody to hire you to talk
okay this experience that slavery is not
particularly economically beneficial is
not shocking as scott sumner of the
library of economics and liberty points
out
brazil didn't abolish slavery until the
1880s and did worse than america
it also did worse than countries to the
south of brazil so we end up with the
absurd spectacle of matthew desmond
suggesting
that the quote-unquote brutality of
american capitalism is modeled in
slavery
i've
[Applause]
honestly i've offered i've offered the
opportunity for this gentleman to be
first in the q a line and now he's
actually just disrupting the ability of
everybody else to hear the speech
honestly i have a three-year-old who
disrupts this way
okay is this your last chance we're
gonna count to three
but the continuation of income disparity
among races in the united states
is today overwhelmingly not the result
of racism jim crow or slavery
income mobility and disparity is a
statistic that should worry us
honestly
[Applause]
honestly i'm i'm more than happy to have
this person ask a question but this is
now the
fourth time that we've been interrupted
during the speech
sir if you can't keep your if you can't
at least sit down and be respectful to
the other what 1500 people in the room
then get up and leave
[Applause]
i'm simply not going to continue this
nonsense until this person
leaves frankly i can't i'm sorry i can't
continue this is silly
[Music]
yes
[Applause]
i appreciate it honestly that's too bad
because i
you heard it i offered multiple times
for him to ask the very first question
i'm more than happy to talk about the
points i'm not more than happy to have
someone disrupt a speech for 500 other
people
because he can't keep his mouth shut so
long as the speech continues
uh as ben states uh leftist questions
will be sent automatically to the front
of the line
we encourage all disagreement you stand
here speaking about races of saying that
you are on a high pedestal
but you continue to deny our humanity in
existence no you're a human being i just
deny that if you're a man who says
you're a woman you're a woman
[Applause]
i'm unaware of any i'm again unaware of
any erasure i'm literally talking to you
right now you're a human being standing
in front of me and i'm talking to you
no it's it's as simple as that you're a
human being i mean if you want to
identify something else i'm sorry you
can't do that either